hello and welcome to the daily climate
show coming up
we report from antarctica where
scientists are rebuilding the history of
the oceans in a bid to help the future
on the brink of famine hundreds die in
the horn of africa as the worst droughts
in four decades continues
and national treasure sir david
attenborough receives his second
knighthood to services for conservation
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show we
track the changes happening to our world
examine the impact those changes are
having and hear from the people coming
up with solutions so almost
three-quarters of britain's believe our
oceans need more protecting that's
according to a yougov pole taken to mark
world ocean day well today less than
eight percent of the world's oceans are
protected but scientists estimate that
30 percent of land and sea need to be
protected by 2030 to create a healthy
ocean and help stabilize the climate in
antarctica scientists are using
cutting-edge dna techniques to
reconstruct
the history of marine life before human
interference sky science correspondent
thomas more filmed with them exclusively
in antarctica two years ago where they
were looking at the impact the
industrial whaling had on the marine
ecosystem and we pick up the story on
world ocean day as the first tantalizing
results start to come in
the skeletons of deception island's
brutal past still scatter its beach
a hundred years ago it was one of the
most important whaling stations in
antarctica
the rusting pressure cookers turned
thousands of tons of blubber into lamp
oil but the onshore stations couldn't
compete with the arrival of industrial
factory ships able to butcher and
process whales out at sea it allowed the
fleets to plunder the oceans with brutal
efficiency with catastrophic
consequences for antarctica's giants
now scientists are trying to piece
together the impact of the slaughter on
the whole ecosystem these are columns of
mud lifted from the antarctic seabed
they contained dna signatures of life in
the sea at the time and the deeper in
the mud they're buried the further back
they go
its environmental history
a lot of the baleen whales are eating
krill suddenly there's fewer whales a
smaller whale population so that's going
to have immediate impacts on the krill
the zooplankton and there'll be knock-on
effects right the way through the
ecosystem and so we want to see if we
can detect those changes before whaling
starts to see what the situation was
before whaling started
two years on and the scientists are back
in their university labs trawling
through the dna signatures
so far they've found marine life in one
antarctic fjord crashed 30 to 40 years
ago for as yet unknown reasons and as
they go back further in time they should
see the impact of whaling
the fact that we have um
a significant change which has obviously
occurred at a particular point in time
is a heartening result it's showing that
we are uh in in a
in a
very sort of broad brush kind of way we
are able to reconstruct something
meaningful about about the the ocean
system
since commercial whaling stopped in the
1980s the population of some antarctic
species has begun to increase but no one
knows how many whales there should be
by reconstructing a healthy ocean
scientists will have a better idea
whether marine conservation is anywhere
near ambitious enough
thomas more sky news
the world must widen its gaze from the
war in ukraine to prevent somalia
sliding into famine that's the message
from the united nations children's
agency as the country suffers its most
severe drought in more than 40 years now
for
rainy seasons in a row have fouled in
the horn of africa and experts predict a
fifth below average season later this
year that's leaving millions facing
severe hunger across the region now
drought is made more intense and more
frequent by climate change and with food
supplies being hit by the war in ukraine
millions in the region are now at risk
aid agencies say more than one and a
half million children are malnourished
and around 3 million livestock have died
since last year due to drought and
disease and that's just in somalia many
are having to walk long distances for
medical care and are forced to leave
vulnerable and sick family members
behind
i had 12 children but four died in this
drought of the eight who survived i had
to leave four behind
they were sick
this little one was the most unwell so i
brought him here to save him
now for more of the day's climate news
and new research suggests rich countries
are only delivering around half the
money promised to less wealthy countries
to help them adapt to climate change the
international institute for environment
and development says developed countries
will fall more than 18 billion short of
the sun promised at cop 26. it comes as
negotiators meet in bond to monitor
progress made since glasgow ahead of a
g7 summit where the uk hopes to put
pressure on other developed nations
brazilian police have opened a criminal
investigation into the disappearance of
a british environmental journalist in
the amazon dom phillips and his guide
bruno pereira were last seen on sunday
morning in an area known for violent
conflict between fishermen poachers and
government agents the journalist has
written extensively about the threats
facing the amazon including how cattle
farming is fueling an environmental
crisis and how illegal gold miners
encroach on
indigenous territory
fossil fuel company equinor has admitted
to sky news that it should be investing
more money into renewable energy the
norwegian oil giant spent around 8.6 of
its capital expenditure on renewables in
2020 but plans to increase that to 30
percent in 2025 and 50 by 2030 equinor
plans to make the humber the world's
first net zero industrial region by 2040
with a hydrogen power project and a
gas-filled plant with carbon capture and
storage both in the pipeline
now it was meant to be european union's
big solution wasn't it to the soaring
energy prices to reliance on russian
fossil fuels and to the climate crisis
but today
in a series of votes meps rejected key
parts of eu climate legislation known as
fit45 that's the package of measures
aimed to reduce the blocks greenhouse
gas emissions by 55 before 2030 and to
accelerate the move before towards
renewable energy well our europe
correspondent adam parsons joins me now
uh from brussels so and tell us why is
this so important
it's important because the european
union is the third biggest
emitter in the world uh it's also
important because this is one of the
real big policies that have been put
forward by the european commission
president ursula von de line
she has really thrown her weight behind
reforming european economies making them
greener cutting emissions european
commissioners put forward its proposals
and then as is the way in this rather
byzantine structure you have here they
then get to go up to the european
parliament now the expectation was that
today
these uh would all go through in a
marathon voting process that the
european parliament would effectively
rubber stamp these proposals
and that they would then go into the
next stage which is to be discussed by
european parliaments themselves well
that hasn't happened why well because of
a big political dispute between
effectively left-wing politicians green
mep's
and much more right-wing or indeed
center right politicians who argued that
these emissions trading's targets needed
to be rethought that they shouldn't be
so extreme now because of the impact of
hugely rising energy prices and also of
the financial strain caused by the war
in ukraine they said they should be
watered down that slowly happened and
then uh i have to say meps from from the
far left and far right decided no this
had all gone too far and ripped up the
proposals and threw them back to the
committee said we need something
new something that everyone can agree on
so what we effectively have is one group
saying these need to be watered down
another one says we won't do it and we
are in a state of deadlock the latest i
have is that one person close to this
deal said a deal could a revised deal
might be done as soon as tomorrow or it
might take months
okay adam thanks very much for that
and finally sir david attenborough's
been knighted for the second time
the broadcaster has been awarded the
most distinguished order of saint
michael and saint george for services to
television and to conservation the
prince of wales himself committed
environmentalist knighted the 96 year
old national treasure as an investiture
ceremony at windsor castle
well that's all from us we'll see you
next time bye